but this book danica the reason i'm so
passionate about it this is the first
time i'm sharing my full playbook
of these teachings that are you know
buried in thousands of pages of ancient
text and really showing how useful and
helpful they are today in helping us to
alleviate suffering get past fear live
our best lives really step into our
creative power and our confidence which
i believe is possible for anybody and
their support of science and stories to
show their relevance yeah
which is great and there's there's like
calls to action yes when you say
playbook as i'm reading it i'm like it
totally is because you hit on so many
different topics and sometimes i read a
book about spirituality or
um
you know some sort of facet of wellness
and yeah you know you could have
probably taken this book and made five
different books out of it you know you
could have a book that just has to do
more with meditation and connection with
your body and then you could have done
another one that has to do with like
you know um you know the relationship
with the outside world and things like
you could have probably broken this down
into so many different books but you
didn't and you really kept it concise
which i love and then i also love that
at the end of the chapters that there's
there's ways to to to go deeper into
what it is that you're talking about
with prompts and questions and
and and ways to guide people through
certain steps whether it be
breathing or meditation or just how to
sit even during your meditation
um and and i just think that that's so
great because it's it's like one of
those things you know it's like going to
a wellness conference and you leave
feeling like so buzzed and energized and
excited and then you know a couple days
later you're kind of like back to normal
because nothing's changed and so
i love that there's ways that people can
go deeper and that you encourage them
from the very beginning in the book
where you say get a journal out and get
ready to start writing because that's
such a huge part of it and i've found
that with my own practice is that the
more that i say things out loud the more
that i write them down the more that i
get these really
gems of prompts make you just open up
like a flower and sometimes there's rain
water in the flower in the form of tears
but
so beautiful so so so beautiful
well thank you love and
it's true that the subtitle of the book
is practical enlightenment for everyday
life and so it was so important to me
that the book was is practical because
to your point sometimes i read i love
eckhart tolle i read his stuff and then
i'm like this sounds really great i'm on
board with the philosophy but how do i
really live this right so every chapter
like you said whether it's going into
confidence there's a 90-second reset if
you start to find yourself in comparison
mode or triggered or whatever it is to
come back same thing with abundance and
so on and so forth um so the book is
structured in three parts the first is
getting past the biggest blocks because
if we don't get past the biggest blocks
including fear um hold the wholeness
chapter is seeing that we are beyond our
behaviors then we can't really get on
the path in the first place and so the
word enlightenment is about freedom
it's about more awareness it doesn't
mean we're gonna be fully enlightened
like jesus or buddha but just getting on
the path and having practices
starts to shift our energy little by
little every single day and so the
meditations i teach the practical
enlightenment meditations are usually
like seven minutes right so i'm not
asking people to do a complete overhaul
of their life if the titanic was turned
one degree from the beginning of the
journey history would have been changed
and then the second part of the book is
embodying more of the qualities of the
true self
um like confidence um intuition peace
and then the third part danica is really
um exciting we don't want to skip ahead
to that but the longest chapter in the
book is called you are a creator and
it's about once we've established part
one and two it's how do we work with our
unique energy and our unique gifts which
are formless they're energetic and how
do we extract that and put it through
these exercises into actual form into
creating our best
product or idea or
website or whatever it is so there's a
very practical nature to this
and what you mentioned before about
journaling
there's eight limbs of yoga you know
back to this core concept that yoga is
really about union and the the essential
message of this book is how do you
connect to this often dormant part of
you that's called the true self that is
the goal of yoga and within the niyamas
which are the second limb of yoga
there's something called
which is introspection and self-study so
yoga is laid out for thousands of years
this whole process of introspection
that's why the journaling prompts are
really important not just reading these
teachings or this information but seeing
huh what are my patterns how does this
apply to me what are my wounds or my
triggers or ways that i act out of the
ego versus the true self
energy
so it keeps um again it's it's relevant
and it's practical and um it is possible
i believe to create great change in your
life with these teachings i love wayne
dyer calls ego edging god out
as an acronym and it's so true so let's
talk about the true self because that's
something like
you know at the core like you said the
true self um the what you're trying to
get to and i love also in the book how
you talk about like that true self like
the center of everything is always the
promise
which is such a beautiful
visualization of it um but maybe it's
starting with the question of because
there's going to be a lot of people like
including what is the true self yeah
exactly like it's hard to know like even
if we just know who we to know who we
really are is a challenge and like it's
a journey and i don't know if i'll ever
be off of that ever ever finish that
journey the the um hopefully i get to
the point where i feel much more wrapped
up hands wrapped around the truth and
through nature and the true self um
and i've come a long way but like why is
it that people have such a hard time
just even getting to the point where
they know who they are when i was like
married a hundred years ago
like there used to be a lot of drinking
and then the next relationship there was
none
and like even in this environment any
example of like all this way all that
way i went i don't know who i am
and like it took me years to really
figure out even where i was in the ebb
and flow of something just like that
you know which is something probably
practical that a lot of people
participate in on a regular basis and
it's like so when i say who you really
are it's like who are you minus
everything else why is that so hard
great so there's like a million things i
want to say about this i love this
question danica so first of all um the
the
the issue the biggest issue i see today
hands down across
everything the reason people i believe
suffer so much the reason there's so
much comparison feeling not enough
feeling not good enough all of these um
like
these forms of suffering come from one
root cause which is that we over
identify with the ego the pseudo soul so
what wayne dyer calls the less than two
percent of who we are so what is the ego
the ego is this part of us that's
sensing with the five senses so it's
what we see with our physical eyes
including looking in the mirror what we
look like what other people are doing on
social media it's always looking out
touching hearing what's out here
right so there's we are having an
embodied experience we are here in a
physical body so of course we are going
to have an ego to an extent we need to
be in the world but the issue is when we
put our full identity and our self-worth
in this
right so the true self what yoga teaches
us is this formless part of us
so it's not something we can see with
our physical eyes necessarily it's
beyond what we look like and it's also
beyond what we do so i want to get to
behavior in a moment
so
this part of us is it's the voice of the
the heart of the intuition it's this
part of us that's beyond thought like
eckhart used to always say beyond
thought i didn't really know what he was
talking about but we tune into this
stable um resource inside of us this
courageous infinitely creative
um intelligence inside of us when we
learn we've got to get to know it so
first of all we need to spend time out
in the world and balance that with inner
connection meditation stillness being in
nature because otherwise like you said
we get very confused and we start to
identify who we are without here so
anytime you you're saying to yourself
hmm
i don't feel good enough you see
something that triggers you like someone
walks by and you're like oh i should be
i should be 10 pounds lighter or
whatever or something happens or you
know whatever you see a social media
post and you think whatever it is
it's important that first of all in that
moment you pause and that feeling comes
up you start to recognize it and you say
oh
i'm identifying with my ego in this
moment
right that is what all of that is
because when we are connected to the
true self we understand that we are this
unique creation of spirit and no one can
be us and no one um we can't be anyone
else so in the confidence chapter
i talk about the difference between
surface confidence and true confidence
surface confidence is in the ego so it's
like i'm you know
i've got really great skin or like look
at my achievements so for me used to be
like look at my straight a's it was all
like my worth was in my grades always my
perfectionism but the problem is out
here is this swirl of dynamic change all
the time so if we pin our confidence to
anything out here it's always going to
go up and down so the true source of
confidence yoga teaches us and when you
peel away the layers and the layers and
you keep going deeper and deeper is one
thing danica it's very simple
it's when you know the statement when
when moses asked the almighty
you know what is this what are you and
it was one statement i am that i am
right so confidence in the very purest
sense comes from i am
i'm here i'm alive i'm breathing i'm a
drop of consciousness i'm spirit
individualized whatever word you want to
use you know the universe whatever but i
am here i am present i am alive and that
is where the real confidence comes from
so the more we anchor into that
like i was saying with my example of you
know i was doing these practices and
then there just started to be this flow
um we start to understand that really
life um transforms like we transform our
lives from the inside out
so a lot of us engage in this arduous
pushing externally the ego is like
wanting to say oh you need to do more
you need to get more even the way we
approach love we think we need to get
love from other people we need to get
this and this and that's the ego um
playing out lack
and the opposite is when we realize that
we are in charge of our we can what we
can work with is our inner state
yeah and it's this frequency inside of
us abundance is really showing with the
fullness of this moment so we're we're
here and we're present we're breathing
and we're not lacking anything we're not
comparing ourselves we're not in ego
identification we are in connection with
this essence inside of us and then that
repeated frequency over time starts to
attract and create people are drawn to
you people say oh what are you what is
this what are you working on they want
to you know opportunities come and more
relationships things get deeper um and
deeper and so it's this beautiful
unfolding danica of your entire life
which is why i'm so passionate about
this book is because i've seen in my own
life and i talk about in the book some
really hard times i've been through and
some really you know um
uh challenging to say at least uh
personal relationships and things that i
have
transcended to now live you know and i
got deeper and deeper into this after my
you know rock bottom place about four
years ago and now i'm like oh my gosh it
doesn't have to be as arduous and
pushing and living from the ego as we've
been led to believe there's this whole
other way of living